voilà les artisans boulangers pâtissiers
français on a douleur de vous faire part
du décès imminent de leur profession
suite à une longue agonie c'est un écrit
tout pour le moins surprenant qui depuis
peu a remplacé petit pain et croissants
dans la vitrine de Raphaël et Sylvie un
avis de décès symbolique synonyme de
fermeture définitive de leur boulangerie
c'est la mort
on perd tout d'un jour à l'autre
on se retrouve pratiquement à la rue
ça va mais pour l'instant
installer un vieux Charmont depuis 2019
le couple avait repris cette affaire
plutôt confiant Raphaël au fourneau
Sylvie seul derrière son comptoir
la situation financière est devenue
catastrophique des charges étouffantes
des matières premières de plus en plus
chères plus 50 à 60% sur certains
produits
grâce à des personnes qui venaient tous
les jours mais c'est pas suffisant c'est
pas faire non pas tenir comme ça
il aurait fallu qu'on ouvre que le matin
et puis qu'on a le travailler ailleurs
l'après-midi qu'on nous a suggéré non
bah non le constat est d'autant plus
amer qu'un vieux Charmont cette
boulangerie était la seule de la commune
pour les 2800 habitants il y a plus
grand chose il y a plus que le bureau de
tabac
c'est pour ça que nous moi je vais
partir je vais partir d'ici
seule solution désormais allez chercher
sa baguette au bar tabac du coin qui
fait désormais office de dépôt on touche
pas d'argent dessus c'est pour dépanner
est-ce que bon un village sent sans
boulangerie c'est un peu triste donc
c'est pour dépanner tout simplement
prenez pas né le village quoi qu'on fait
ça en attendant un éventuel repreneur
d'autres habitants eux préfèrent se
rendre jusqu'à chouchou où les
boulangeries ne manquent pas enfin pour
l'instant